When a person used the rice machine too much, well, the easy answer to that is no.
We have some patients that have been hospitalized that I've written long programs. I mean,
literally wrote programs that were, you know, over 70 hours long that said that they didn't have to
turn it on and off, you know, very often. So it was just running constantly while the person was
in their hospital bed. So the easy answer is no, you don't know, you know, way you could do too much,
but the more depth answer is it really depends on what program you're running. So if you're running
cancer programs, the answer is no, you really can't do too much right feet. But if you're running
kill programs, what's a kill program? So if you're running like parasite kill programs or bacterial
kill programs, especially if it's gram negative bacteria like Lyme disease, yes, you could do too much.
So if we have a patient that comes to us and they want me to program the rice machine for their
Lyme disease, then I would say, okay, well, we have to go really slow and we have to maybe, we have
to do sometimes multiple changes to the program. Sometimes I've given the person right off the bat
multiple different programs where you start off with a very short amount of kill in the program
of overnight program. There's a lot more detox frequencies in that program. And then we, you know,
as they can tolerate that, then we go up with higher kill rate times as far as
let me be able to tolerate that because when you kill a gram negative bacteria too quickly,
you'll liberate lipopolysaccharides and that would cause a herximer reaction. And you don't want to
do that with people with Lyme disease. So with Lyme disease patients, yes, you could do too much
rifing if you're running bacteria kill programs. So could a Lyme disease patient run detox programs
and overdose on the detox programs? No, no, you can't because the detox programs in the rice are mainly
to stimulate liver function and kidney function. They're not like key-ladied stuff out of your
tissue and could overwhelm your detox pathways. That's not how the rife works. So, and that's what's
in everybody's cancer program understands. So in your cancer program, I have some detox things in
your cancer program as well, but mainly you're running cancer frequencies all night long. And you're
recycling those frequencies. So if you wouldn't search through the different your your program and looked
at all those numbers, each night is actually similar. You know, so I mix it up so that if you,
and the reason why you mix it up is like, okay, you're going to bed at night and maybe people are
very habitual. They go to bed at night at clock every night. Then they get up at one o'clock to go
to the bathroom and they're in the bathroom for, you know, half hour and they would miss their program
frequencies from one to one to 30 every single night. Well, tomorrow's the frequencies are going to be
different at that time. So they're mismatched around so you won't miss them. Or a person's like I never
end up finishing my program because I always end up getting up early and it's still running
in my missing frequencies. Well, if you're getting up three hours early every day, yeah, we should
probably shorten your program. But if you're sometimes finishing the program and sometimes getting up
half hour early and sometimes, you know, getting up 15 minutes early, I mean, don't worry about it
because you're getting those programs mixed up in there. But every cancer patient, the majority of
the frequencies in their program are cancer programs. There's some liver clans, there's some
different things depending on the cancer that person had, sometimes depending upon our initial
conversation. And often when when I rewrite a program for a person, it's depending upon what tested out
with that or maybe a conversation I had with them, maybe they're having new issues. So I'll put
different other things in that program. So, but for a cancer patient, no, it's never, you could never
do too much right feet. We have some cancer patients that might be listening to this call right now
that are running it all the all night long. They're running it all day long because they're not really
you know, very ambulatory. And they're you know, and if you're not going to be, you know, if you're
going to be sitting watching TV or reading a book, you should be running the right getting as much
right time in as possible. And I've stated many times that the big error that people make is that
they are not running the right enough. Sometimes we can we can purchase right machines back and
I can look and see, you know, how often the person ran their program. And many times, you know,
a person passes away. They've run their program a lot. And that's that's great. And we did give it
everything we could. And we gave it our best shot. We know that. But sad what I get what I get a
right back from a spouse who has passed away and they haven't run the right for eight months. It's like,
what? I don't I don't understand. If you have this machine, you should be using it in the and it's
going to do you zero good if you're not running it as much as you possibly can. I've stated many times
when I was at my sickest, I was running it all night long. I dragged to work and then I turned the
right on at work. I had it on all day at work. And then I'd get home and I turned it on immediately when
I got home. So I was running the right some days, at least 20 hours a day. So and I attribute that to
really getting me over my cancer. So and putting me in a state of revision that I'm in. So
you can't do too much cancer right feed. Long story. Long answer to that. But